[Music]
Nickelodeon characters have been making
us laugh for years can you believe we
actually managed to find them in real
life
wait until you see number one don't
forget to hit that notification belt and
never miss another video and be sure to
check out our community section for even
more fun now let's check out 15
Nickelodeon characters in real life
Roger Klotz from Doug let's start with
the one and only Doug it's one of the
most iconic Nickelodeon cartoons and if
you've never seen it you need to check
it out of course you won't be able to
find a lot of cartoon characters in real
life but we managed to bring out some of
the best look-alikes
starting with McLemore doesn't he look
like a real-life version of Roger Klotz
Roger is the school bully in the cartoon
known to cause a mess wherever he goes
he does have his moments sometimes but
they somehow always end up getting
overshadowed by his bully trait although
we don't think Macklemore really acts
like Roger Klotz in real life the
resemblance is uncanny except for the
whole green skin part what do you think
could McLemore passes Rogers twin we
think this is pretty spot-on and it'll
only get better
timmy turner from The Fairly OddParents
if you don't remember Doug you might be
more familiar with a show like The
Fairly OddParents it's still a pretty
popular show and everyone is still in
love with timmy turner the old fashioned
way by being me although he's full of
pride and can often be seen as arrogant
timmy is also incredibly witty which
makes him instantly likable the internet
seems to think that the Lord of the
Rings star Elijah Wood is actually a
real-life timmy turner
we hope he's not as arrogant but we
actually do see the resemblance in their
faces just look at those ginormous eyes
although we can't imagine Timmy
playing a part in the Lord of the Rings
because let's be honest that would be
just a little bit bizarre or maybe not
considering the Lord of the Rings isn't
actually a totally normal movie anyway
but you have to admit elijah does share
some similarities with the cartoon
character Chuckie Finster from Rugrats
okay this one made us giggle just a
little bit so many celebrities actually
look like Nickelodeon characters and as
our list goes on you'll see that it only
gets funnier but this one is one of our
faiths it's ed Sheeran as the one and
only Chuckie Finster from Rugrats
who doesn't love Rugrats you have to be
honest this is one of the best
comparisons ever just look at the hair
well I do it I do it I do it we hope ed
was actually a much calmer kid than the
kids from the Rugrats were even though
we can't blame them
those kids are awesome and they were
definitely a part of our childhood if
you've never seen the crazy Chucky in
action you're in for a real treat we're
telling you there's no way ed Sheeran is
that neurotic but they really do look
alike debby Thornbury from The Wild
Thornberrys welcome to The Wild
Thornberrys a cartoon about a nomadic
family that's filming a documentary
series about their lives they think
they're totally normal except they're
not not really just check out what
Eliza's 18 year old sister Debbie looks
like she's known to have quite the
temper so we feel like Kesha would
totally be her real-life look-alike same
wild hair although we vet Kesha is
actually much nicer in person but of
course everyone needs a little bit of
Debbie sass don't they if you're not
familiar with The Wild Thornberrys you
absolutely have to watch this cartoon
especially if you're into travel and you
know talking animals my name is but my
friends call me what do you think it
would be impossible to find a human with
Debbie's face but when it comes to big
gorgeous hair
Kesha is totally nailing Debbie's look
Courtney crippling from as told by
ginger
here's another oldie but goodie to add
on your list we know you probably love
Nickelodeon cartoons like the loud house
too so don't worry we've included one of
our favorite loud house characters in
this video but first let's talk about
the old school cartoon that is as told
by ginger Courtney grip Ling is a part
of a best friend trio that goes on
various adventures she has blond hair
styled in a bob and people seem to think
that the American actress Chelsea Kane
totally looks like a real-life Courtney
can't you see it the hair is definitely
spot-on of course
Courtney's other facial features are
much harder to replicate in real life
probably for the best
no offense to Kourtney of course wait do
cartoon characters get offended but if
Nickelodeon ever decides to reboot as
told by ginger they should definitely
call Chelsea King Marshall from paw
patrol we love paw patrol on this
channel even though we know that it's
one of the most infamous shows that
parents have a love/hate relationship
with paw Patrol is all about adorable
dogs
saving the world Marshall is a friendly
dalmatian puppy who's known to be
extremely brave and helpful just look
how adorable user knows Roy dolmage and
here's the real-life version of Marshall
of course it's an actual animal what did
you expect and an adorable one at that
seriously the paw patrol costume totally
melts our hearts just put them in the
actual paw patrol already please this
doggy would fit right in with the rest
if there's ever a paw patrol movie with
actual dogs they know who to call this
doggy looks like he's totally ready to
save the entire world and that paw
patrol outfit is only making him more
confident
Rhonda Wellington Lloyd from hey Arnold
if you're totally new to the old-school
Nickelodeon cartoons you should
definitely watch Hey Arnold before
anything else
in fact we bet that even if you've never
seen the cartoon you've heard about
hammer this iconic show comes with an
iconic character known as Rhonda Rhonda
sporting black hair usually cut in a
short bob she's known as the spoiled kid
with a lot of attitude and even though
we're sure vanessa hudgins from high
school musical is nothing like rhonda in
real life she does kind of look like her
don't you think she could definitely
pass as a human version of Rhonda
Vanessa looks so sweet but she's
definitely talented enough to play
Rhonda if she ever gets a chance to hey
Nickelodeon take a hint
Lucy loud from the loud house okay let's
get to one of our absolute favorite
Nickelodeon shows and one of our fav
garrick ters ever it's the one and only
Lucy loud from the loud house how could
you not love the forever moody Lucy that
basically represents the teenage phase
most of us go through in our lives
low key fan 18 from deviantART cosplay
as Lucy and amazingly portrayed what
Lucy would look like in real life just
look at all that hair all they need to
do now
is recite tons of poetry and basically
replace all their wardrobe with dark
clothing you know someone please hand me
my poetry journal I have some very
strong feelings to express and of course
having ten other siblings wouldn't hurt
either but we bet even this cosplayer is
lucky they don't have to go through all
that to become a real-life Lucie loud
this deviantART user totally pulled this
off Patrick Starr from Sponge Bob
here's another favorite Nickelodeon
character how could you not love Patrick
sure he has his ways of thinking but you
have to admit that SpongeBob SquarePants
wouldn't be the same without this iconic
starfish did you know you can become a
real-life patrick Star you can actually
buy an awesome Patrick costume that's
totally realistic of course you'd still
need to be as funny and dim-witted as
the good old Patrick is this the Krusty
Krab this is Patrick but if you can pull
that off
you'll be completely iconic seriously
just look at this awesome cartoon loving
the pants in the belly button detail
what do you think would you ever put on
a patrick star costume or is that just a
little bit too much don't worry we're
not done yet more real-life Nickelodeon
characters are coming up next
LuAnn from the loud house you know we
love the loud house on this channel and
if you didn't know well now you know and
you just have to watch some of our other
videos on the show it's our absolute
fave with so many characters to choose
from it's hard to pick favorites but
along with Lucy LuAnn is also among the
top five deviantART user Jen alt - zero
one angel and she really pulled it off
she even added the flower detail in her
iconic yellow outfit but do you think
she had the dad jokes to complete
Luann's look we all know LuAnn is always
spot on with everything she says even
though her puns can get just a little
bit annoying after a while
did you hear the one about the thief who
stole a calendar he got 12 months but
this cosplayer is far from annoying this
is a perfect representation of what
LuAnn would look like in real life
Danny Fenton from Danny Phantom before
we move on to our top four nickelodeon
characters and their real-life
look-alikes we have to talk about Danny
Phantom we're pretty sure no one has
awesome ghost powers and real
but that's what makes this cartoon so
special the main character of the
cartoon is Danny Fenton and he is the
absolute coolest character ever just
look at that hair people have compared
the singer Adam Lambert to Danny Adams
hair is actually amazing and we can
totally see the resemblance sure he
might not have any superpowers other
than singing when you're that awesome
who needs them item could totally pull
off the Danny Fenton look and make it
even better with his haircut seriously
we're still not over it isn't he the
most perfect real Danny Fenton but can
he become the cool Danny Phantom that is
the question handsome Squidward from
SpongeBob Sponge Bob fans this one's for
you
and we're totally serious we found a
real-life version of Squidward's
alter-ego if you're not familiar with
handsome Squidward you need to rewatch
the two faces of Squidward episode since
that episode the handsome version of
Squidward became somewhat of a meme but
can you imagine that there's a celebrity
out there that could be his real-life
version the internet seems to think that
grant Kemp from The Bachelorette could
totally pull off the handsome Squidward
look honestly we can kind of see it of
course it doesn't hurt the grant camp is
already gorgeous but can he actually
rival the handsome Squidward he's
another person that could definitely
play that version if nickelodeon ever
decides to do a live action movie of
spongebob and obviously we expect
handsome Squidward to be in that
live-action movie if that ever happened
helga Pataki from hey Arnold
we already talked about Rhonda from hey
Arnold but we have to also mention the
complex person that is Helga whether you
were cheering on her love for Arnold or
not you have to admit that Helga is
something special and her blonde
pigtails look is absolutely iconic a
deviantART user that goes by the name of
CAC tam e you got it
recreated a real-life version of Helga
and she really pulled it off check it
out we're loving the hair and the added
bow although we sincerely hope this
cosplayer isn't as obsessive about boys
as Helga but you have to admit that she
looks absolutely perfect in that dress
though
and that wig if you look closely you can
even spot Helga's monobrow which is
definitely one of our most unique
characteristics we love Helga but we
also love this cosplayer plankton from
Sponge Bob we're not done with SpongeBob
SquarePants just yet since it's
Nickelodeon's longest and most popular
show yet you know we have to dedicate
some time to these amazing characters
many have tried to recreate real-life
versions of them but not a lot we're
able to pull them off it's hard to
recreate a real-life version of plankton
but did you know that you can easily do
it yourself you can actually buy a
plankton costume although he's not a
favorite spongebob character plankton is
actually pretty underrated we loved his
determination to get the krabby patty
formula and his sense of humor you might
not be able to get as tiny as plankton
but you can look like him with this
costume seriously this is absolutely
perfect
SpongeBob SquarePants are you ready kids
okay just kidding we won't make you do
this bunch pop theme song but we will
show you this absolutely hilarious
real-life version of spongebob spongebob
is one of those happy-go-lucky
characters you just can't help but love
sure he has his odd qualities but it's
precisely what makes him so lovable it's
no wonder so many people love to watch
this crazy character but how could you
possibly recreate spongebob in real life
sure you could put on a costume but
that's not what we found are you ready
for this it's a sponge that's exactly
what spongebob is isn't it just a
regular yellow sponge you can probably
find somewhere in your house gotcha and
that's it for our video who's your
favorite Nickelodeon character come let
us know in the comments and don't forget
to subscribe to the things for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
see you next time
[Music]